so let's say I have tables where I can
fit one person at either of the short
ends of the table so I could fit one
person there I could fit one person
there you could view this is we're
looking down we're looking from above
the table here so we could put one
person at either of the short ends of
the table and then on these longer ends
right over here we can fit two people we
can fit two people at the longer end so
when you have one table so when you have
one table you could fit one two three
four five six people you could fit six
people now let's think about what
happens as we add tables end to end to
this table right over here so let's
imagine now two tables so here we have
one table and it's going to touch ends
with this table right over here and
because it touches ends right over here
we're kind of making it one big
continuous table you can't fit someone
here anymore so now how many people can
we fit let's see we can fit one two
three four five and then on this table
which is identical you could fit six
seven eight nine and then you could put
one person at the end right over here so
when you have two tables you can now fit
end to end you can now fit a total of
ten people let's keep going and see if
we can think of a pattern here so let's
put three tables here so one table two
tables and three tables so just as
before we could put one at each end so
that's two people then we have three
four five six seven eight nine 10 11 12
13 14 folks 14 folks so what does it
look like is happening here well if you
just look at the numbers we went from 6
to 10 to 14 it looks like we're adding
it looks like we're adding four people
every time we actually add a table now
does that actually make sense so let's
think about this first situation let's
imagine these are real people I'll make
this person in blue right over here if
you were to bring over this new table if
you bring over table - so this is table
1 if you bring over table 2 this blue
person has to move
and so where could they move us say that
they always insist on sitting at the end
of a table so the blue person moves to
the new end of the table the new end of
the table they move right over here so
how many new people could move to this
combined table now that you brought that
second table in well the new people the
new people I will do in I will do in
this purple color the new people are
that person let me do it in a more
unique color this person this person
this person and this person so you were
able to add four new people with a new
table one way to think about it is a new
table is going to have one usable end
here that usable end is going to be
taken by the person who is already at
the usable end of when you had less
tables and so you're really able to the
real addition is the two sides here so
you're adding four people every time you
add a table so it makes complete sense
so based on this you could think about
without even having to draw these
diagrams what would happen or how many
people you would be able to fit if you
had four or five or six or however many
tables so you could imagine if you have
if you have four tables we just have to
add four and you should be able to sit
18 people if you have five tables you
should be able to fit 22 people and on
and on and on